the two left feet was one of the
biggest laughs i harmonized god
loves a terrier he was the balloon
i was the string i mean it's very clear
as you watch the movie 20 years later
that
these people are having a really good
time i did not know that
and i wanted the bucks i knew i was
going to lose an eyelash doing this
i have to tell you looking at the six of
you
does my weary 20 20 heart a lot of good
seeing you guys back together catherine
you know this is where we we kind of
fell in love with you and
eugene together so congratulations on 20
years
for this film she had dozens of
boyfriends
hundreds hundreds
when you were making it though did you
just think like
we're getting together and we're doing
this kind of quirky movie we're just
gonna have a hell of a lot of fun
or did you all know yeah there's some
real
magic here uh there was definitely magic
in everyone else watching everyone
improvise was just
the best to just get to see everyone do
what they do
and to accuse people of making up stuff
ahead of time because they were so
quick so great and funny
it was it was lovely eugene is it true
because um i want to try to uncover a
little set secrets is it true that the
audience was cardboard
people the extras i think we had
some people in the crowd but we didn't
have
enough money and chris you probably know
better than me
yeah we could we couldn't load the arena
with people um and uh i seem to recall
maybe some cardboard people do you
um i don't mean in the cast
i mean no sir we shot this in a
very big arena it was probably 20 000
person arena
we didn't have the budget to to fill
that or anywhere near that
we had some actual people and uh we
i think we did make they call them flat
people by the way no disrespect
but the uh flat people
and uh i think uh they were the hardest
to direct because they
don't listen at all they just have this
completely stoning
uh face i was howling
when eugene and catherine were going in
the utility closet and they're ad
just asking like how do we order room
service do we say utility
closet room service that's the good news
you're right next door to the kitchen i
mean literally next door so you grab
somebody and um you know get a menu and
you'll be able to order something from
them
and say just utility closet
well i think a lot of it in the closet
was improvised i mean we did uh
chris and i i guess put down the story
points
about you know what they might be asking
about
when they're in the closet but you know
once you're once you're there and the
camera's on
stuff just comes out of your mouth and
we had a great kind of straight man to
work with
basically who played the hotel yes so
yeah
i found that scene funny even when i was
doing it
don't water the plants they're plastic
christopher
of this motley crew who broke the most
who like just
couldn't i probably would have lasted
two words in and i'd have been dying who
broke the most
generally people don't uh break much at
all
actually and i would say most of the
scenes are improvised but we've all
worked together a lot and
that's not really the vibe is kind of
cracking each other up it's it's more of
a
getting through scenes sometimes it
would last five five to ten minutes long
and uh i don't recall that happening
very much at all
we actually we actually learned on
waiting for
guffman that if you laugh during a scene
when it's being filmed it only makes the
day longer
christopher did you have anyone else
like in mind for anything else or were
you really clear
at everybody typically what happens is
in a movie like this which is improvised
you have to begin with the premise that
you need actors that can improvise so
that it's a fairly small group of people
normally casting a movie you have
hundreds of people potentially but this
is now
narrowed down and it's the people i've
worked with before so that
that's where it all begins yeah was it
true that you cast jane after seeing her
in a serial commercial
we just love kellogg's frosted flakes i
saw jane
and i worked with jane i was actually
shooting a commercial
and we worked together and then uh
i believe she came i ran into her in a
coffee place
and then she came over to my office and
i basically said i'd like you to do this
and she said yeah but no
she was because pretty much thinking
about you know
honey i don't want the bucks that's
great
listen i hope you eat frosted flakes
every day now for the reason because
they were so good
i enjoy a bowl of frosted flakes that is
great
so i want to ask about some of the
inspiration behind some of the gags in
the film so the first one
is those teeth of yours eugene and
actually having two
left feet yes as if one wasn't enough i
thought for some reason i needed those
uh teeth still need them i think
the two left feet was one of the
biggest laughs i think chris and i had
in the office
jerry says i've got two left feet
he's got two left feet that is certainly
a first
go get him pal man i do remember the
moment when that came up and then chris
and i
just looked at each other and i said
no no no okay you can't actually have a
left foot
why because i think it's too much i
think it's
having two left feet i think might be
jim is it funny
yes it's funny but i mean i don't think
this is this one on for 10 minutes
while we were literally going crazy
laughing
that was a big one that was one of the
big ones okay i need to know the
inspiration behind my favorite thing in
the film and that
is god loves a
[Music]
terrier
did that come from and did you all make
that up on the spot
no it was written did you write it
eugene i think um i wrote yes i wrote i
think we had
uh i don't know whether we had the name
god loves a terrier in the
in the outline no i can't remember but
it was
written and i would say eugene wrote it
and the great thing about a cast like
this is they're all musical
eugene wrote the song and then catherine
uh sang it with him yeah
i harmonized yes you did you did yes you
did
harmonized the heck out of that
17 seconds to write that speaking of
michael and michael
i i'm still floored by what you guys did
together
you've already packed six kimonos that's
weird all right so here's seven
we're in philadelphia for 48 hours
really like wha
how the hell were you guys that in sync
at all times well here's our
relationship
uh he was the balloon i was the string
all i had to do was let him go a little
bit and he would go i stepped onto a set
and i was working with my idol you know
that's that's who michael mckeon was to
me i'm really just surprised i
i want to i would emphasize something
gene said which is that
i i'm amazed this movie is so watchable
considering how much fun we were having
you know i mean usually it doesn't work
out that way if
everyone's moving off or just having a
good time it always like goes right in
the toilet onto the screen
and when you're having a miserable time
it's someone that's like oh that was a
brilliant movie
it's very clear as you watch the movie
20 years later that
these people are having a really good
time i heard you guys
talking about it before and we would
really be remiss if we didn't talk about
the late great fred willard
why didn't he put the blood on put on
one of those sherlock holmes hats
and put a little pipe in his mouth are
they ever allowed to do anything like
that christopher i'm going to start with
you why was he the perfect actor
to play the commentator fred uh was
unique
and that's not something i say a lot
about a lot of people fred has this
demeanor i think to the audience he
looks like a regular person
you know good looking guy completely
straight person there's no
irony there's nothing in what he says
that uh betrays his
inner thickness and i think uh
there was only one person that could
play that part and fred i believe eugene
uh you can correct me fred worked for
one day on that film yeah
he did one day of shooting and
it was extraordinary to see to see that
wow yeah
yeah he was there he was there one day
and and you know and i i i may have
mentioned this before but i
i you know when when the idea first came
up i remember saying to chris well
it's a great idea but how
how do we make the third act funny how
do we make a dog show funny because it's
got to be a legitimate dog show for this
thing to work
where are the laughs going to be coming
from and it wasn't until chris said well
what if fred is our
color commentator during the broadcast
and that just made so much sense
and he would he actually would have
reams of notes that he
thought of you know five minutes before
but he also didn't even need them
he was somebody who could think in terms
of set up punchline
i would just like to quote uh martin
maul on the subject of
fred willard he said you know fred
doesn't use his turn signal
perfect perfect
oh my god are you all right whoa whoa
hey look out here
honey somebody put something down here i
just wonder where do you guys all think
your characters would be
you'd be married very happily still uh
auditioning i guess we have some kind of
sad podcast i think
like winky's world or something i don't
know
yeah good that's that is a good one we
would we would have we would have a
podcast
i would like to carry on jerry wouldn't
have too much to say i don't think
because you know he because of the
deterioration that would have gone on
upstairs
i think christy cummings would be
blacklisted from the world
of uh the dog shows for having uh bet
against herself
um and probably is running some
very unsuccessful scams in some other uh
discipline
so good catherine and eugene we love
seeing you guys of course reunite on
shit's creek
ron how was i to know you were in peril
you keep everything inside like a
bashful clam
do you ever think that we you could see
all of you guys reunite
again for another film together i mean
you know that
that would like explode our brains if
that could actually happen
yes please uh it's up to christopher
isn't it
it would be nice okay christopher it's
up to you let's see what we got
yes nod he says yes i have a great
nursing home pitch uh chris
i got a civil yeah reenactment pitch for
[Laughter]
you